Oh
okay so I said I would talk about the
sequels and remakes to a lot of these
movies and with her be oh my god there
are so many it's funny we think of
Disney and all the sequels and
characters that they use that Herbie is
not usually mentioned among them but he
has a ton of sequels and remakes
there's Herbie rides again Herbie goes
to Monte Carlo Herbie goes bananas
there's a remake with Lindsay Lohan and
yes there is even a remake with Bruce
Campbell Bruce Campbell drove her V it's
so friggin weird and pretty much all
these movies range from it to weird and
surreal and I don't know it's hard for
me to think of a movie that was
downright painful like it was so bad I
just wanted to turn it off but at the
same time none of these really grabbed
me that much some of them have some
really surreal moments like in Herbie
rides again
I remember the villain has a dream that
a bunch of evil Herbie's are chasing him
and trying to eat up yeah it's pretty
out there but after that they all kind
of gel together it's somebody
discovering the cars of life trying to
convince themselves it's not alive but
coming around to realizing it is alive
and trying to convince other people that
it's alive them not believing and then
coming around winning some races high
jinks ensue I don't know in all honesty
the idea only had possibility for one
movie and even then it wasn't really
that much possibility they just kind of
got lucky and how goofy it was and how
much passion they put into it but then
again there is sort of this weird funny
charm to some of them as well and just
the idea again Bruce Campbell driving
Herbie just watching him talk to the car
is kind of funny but really that's just
kind of a Kitsch thing like oh isn't it
funny if you know who Bruce Campbell is
and know what Herbie is to see them
together talking but yeah that's not
really enough to make it last around an
entire movie there's one with Lindsay
Lohan and Michael Keaton and yeah what
really annoys me about this one is
remember how I was saying how great it
was before that Herbie never really had
any eyes or he didn't talk or anything
like that well here they tried to give
her be a face
yeah it'll roll its eyes it'll kind of
smile and it really doesn't work
oh no just something about talking cars
they never work for Disney I think it's
more fun if you just kind of guess what
the car is feeling and you kind of put
your own emotions onto it when we
actually see it react to something yeah
it's pretty though
I guess I give it credit that the series
apparently had enough steam for so many
movies and remakes but again I don't
know how many people really talk about
it or remember them I can't like the
Disney direct-to-dvd sequel do you just
kind of go oh that existed and again I
don't recall any that we're like a sin
against nature bad but I don't think any
really require that much of a viewing if
you can check him out I'd say do it just
from mere curiosity don't expect to get
anything that great out of it if you do
have that curiosity go and find out for
yourself